Sales of Grant's packs of 12 nozzles have really taken off. In fact, he's been
doing so well selling these bulk packages, that he's only going to sell nozzles
by the dozen now. That does mean, though, that depending on how many nozzles he
has total, he might have some left over. For example, if Grant has 40 nozzles
total, then that will make 3 and 1 3rd packages of 12 nozzles. Since if we take
40 and divide it by 12, we get 3 and a 3rd. And we can see these 3 whole
packages of 12 nozzles, but then there's this 1 3rd of a package left over.
Grant can't sell 1 3rd of a package. So, this 3 and a 3rd packages really only
counts as 3 for him. So, it's almost as if we're taking this 3 and a 3rd and
rounding it down to the nearest integer, 3. So, let's say that x equals the
actual number of packs of nozzles we have. So, for example in this case, we
have 3 and 3rd packs of nozzles. And let's say that y equals the number of
packs of nozzles that Grant can actually sell. So, in this case, that was 3. We
can represent this relationship between the actual number of packages we have
and the number Grant can sell by something that's called the Floor Function,
also known as the Greatest Integer Function. The notation for the equation is
this, y equals x inside these double square brackets, which basically means
that the y value is equal to the greatest integer that is less than or equal to
the corresponding x value. But what do you think the graph of the 4 function
looks like? Which of these graphs do you think properly represents the floor
function? Remember that we want the y value to round x down to the nearest
integer. I know that from our way it might be hard to tell these graphs apart.
So, below them I've shown a blown up version for you of what each of these
steps looks like. Please notice the difference between the 2 in terms of which
circles are empty and which circles are colored in.